hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
clarifications that Alastair MacIntyre
is going to make about his account of
the virtues in chapter 14 of after
virtue is the degree and the ways in
which it is Aristotelian and we should
specify from the very beginning before
going into that account that there is no
one single monolithic view of what it
means to be a wrist Italian there's you
know certainly a number of different
concepts and approaches that fit within
a kind of constellation but anybody who
tries to tell you that there's some you
know platonic essence of Aristotelian
ISM out there is definitely not
Aristotelian and doesn't know what
they're talking about they may have
gotten that from a philosophy textbook
or from some other author they may be
imagining that there's only Platonism
and aristotelianism running throughout
history all of those sorts of views are
bad history of philosophy and indeed bad
philosophy in general because they they
avoid actually engaging the text of
Aristotle who's a very deep and complex
thinker often difficult to I should add
as well so there is what we can call you
know sort of a generalizable
- Tilly anism but its boundaries are
going to be fuzzy and McIntyre knows
this very well he's already discussed
you know Aristotelian virtue ethics you
know in an Aristotelian way in the
chapter 12 which is titled Aristotle's
account of the virtues and this is not
McIntyre's first time approaching this
he's talked about it in its history of
ethics and many many other places so he
knows what what he means by Aristotelian
ism and if you want to know what he
means by ever you should read the other
chapter as well now he is going to
specify for us the ways in which his
account differs fundamentally from that
of Aristotle and then he's going to
specify the ways in which he views his
account as essentially Aristotelian if
you like to use the word neo
Aristotelian that's perfectly fine it's
a common term in philosophical parlance
MacIntyre usually just talks about his
is you know way of looking at things as
being fundamentally Aristotelian and it
takes the plain person as a potential
Aristotelian we should mention referring
to some of his other essays so how is
the account not Aristotelian well
there's one big way that is very
controversial in part because here in
after virtue he says one thing and then
he modifies it slightly not entirely he
doesn't reject it completely but he
modifies it to some degree in a book
that he writes you know three books
later in the very important for book
series of after virtue whose justice
which rationality three rival versions
of moral inquiry and then dependent
rational animals in which he takes us
back a little bit so what is the thing
that he's saying here he says that
although this account of the virtues is
teleological it does not require any
allegiance to Aristotle's metaphysical
biology so a very sweeping claim no
allegiance no
loyalty no taking something on no
foundation in Aristotle's metaphysical
biology is actually necessary and you
know it's an interesting thing to think
about let's say we didn't actually have
the parts of animals or the history of
animals or you know a few other things
as well and we just had say the ethical
political works meaning the Nicomachean
ethics do Dameon ethics politics
rhetoric and parts of the topics and you
know the poetics let's say we just had
those maybe we also throw in on the soul
as well would you actually say that
there is some sort of metaphysical
biology underlying Aristotle's treatment
of the virtues and indeed is larger
ethics probably not because you're not
going to find too much of it in that
text other than the reference is to like
parts of the soul and higher and lower
functions so MacIntyre is on to
something and he's saying listen we
don't need to buy into Aristotle's
essentially outmoded in many respects
metaphysical biology in order for this
project to work now later on as I
mentioned he's going to say well maybe
we needed some elements of Aristotle's
metaphysical biology but he's not
endorsing you know a return to Aristotle
on all these points the way some people
do and their interpretations so what
does this mean that the account is
teleological but doesn't require
Aristotle's metaphysical biology we can
have other accounts of teleology we can
have other accounts of relations of
means to ends or indeed of complex
functions and what it is for a rational
organism to prosper to do well and also
by contrast to fail to set up
impediments to itself to have
impediments set up to it in terms of you
know it's its matrix that it lives
within of the family of society of
culture all these other things as well
that leads us to the second point
so here McIntyre says something a little
bit longer he says just because of the
multiplicity of human practices and the
consequent multiplicity of goods in the
pursuit of which the virtues may be
exercised goods which will often be
contingently incompatible and which will
therefore make rival claims upon our
Allegiance and by Allegiance he doesn't
mean anything like a blind loyalty to
something or you know foundationalism
you have to have this he just means that
that they compel us right we have to we
have to choose between us he could say
prioritisation and that would probably
be a better term conflict whilst not
spring solely from flaws in individual
character and this is kind of an
interesting thing for him to say so
conflict between these goods is not
going to spring solely from we might say
moral failures a failure to develop it
within a human being
McIntyre thinks that that social forces
and factors and dynamics play a major
role in this as well and here it's
interesting to think about
he might be overshooting the mark a
little bit because Aristotle certainly
recognizes that as well he in the
politics criticizes the barbarians for
mixing up different functions treating
women as if they're just slaves and he
sees this as a sign in which their
societies are giving people wrongheaded
ideas about good and bad and all sorts
of other things he also in in nikka
McCain ethics book 7 talks about various
social practices again barbarians which
lead to people being so damaged that
they're unable to engage in the kind of
moral decision-making that would even
make them vicious he calls this
brutality it's a damaging of the the
higher part of ourselves and he uses
sexual abuse of children as an example
in that so you know MacIntyre
account is not Aristotelian perhaps in
that it places a much much greater
stress on the role of society and
culture and he wants to say here's ways
in which I differ from Aristotle how is
his account Aristotelian well one key
thing that he tells us here which is
very interesting to think about given
that Aristotle isn't the only person to
bring these up he says it requires for
its completion a cogent elaboration of
just those distinctions and concepts
which Aristotle's account requires so
it's it's elaborating the same things
that Aristotle to some degree elaborated
very often Aristotle would give us
outlines which then are filled in but if
you look at the commentator tradition
you know for example Alexander of
Aphrodisias or some of the other
Aristotelian 's you will see these
fleshed out even further which makes
perfect sense given McIntyre's account
of how traditions work so what are these
concepts voluntariness the distinction
between the intellectual virtues and the
virtues of character the relation of
both to natural abilities and the
passions and the structure of practical
reasoning he says on every one of these
topics something very like Aristotle's
view has to be defended if my own
account is to be plausible doesn't mean
that we have to follow Aristotle exactly
in saying for example you know when it
comes to effectivity or desire or excess
there are only three main kinds rational
desirable ASUS spirited desire thumos
and appetite of desire epithelia ever so
it could be wrong about that
but there has to be some account that at
least takes into account what's right in
his views and then goes beyond it and
you can do this within Aristotle this is
a total side note by pointing out that
the path a the emotions are also types
of are exes and that Pro racist is
itself with faculty of choice is also a
type of our exes
as well you know looking at nikka mckay
and ethics books six but these sort of
concepts need to be part of the account
and MacIntyre says we're going to do
that
so it's Aristotelian it gives a much
longer discussion of how his account can
as he says accommodate an Aristotelian
view of pleasure and enjoyment and what
does he mean by this so one thing that
he's focusing on here is the pleasure
and enjoyment that comes through
achieving excellence in a practice
achieving at internal goods as we were
calling them earlier so he says as
Aristotle says the enjoyment of the
activity and the enjoyment of
achievement are not the ends at which
the agent aims but the enjoyment
supervenes on the successful activity in
such a way that the activity achieved
and the activity enjoyed are one and the
same state to aim at the one is to aim
at the other and hence also it's easy to
confuse the pursuit of excellence with
the pursuit of enjoyment in this
specific sense and he thinks that a lot
of people make that mistake and thereby
actually cut themselves off from the
development necessary to enjoy those
internal goods because they treat them
as if they are the same thing as
external goods like prestige status
power and money and a little bit later
on he goes on and talks about how John
Stuart Mill in making the distinction
between higher and lower pleasures in
his work utilitarianism is trying to get
at something like the what MacIntyre
takes to be the Aristotelian treatment
of pleasures and enjoyment and he says
something very interesting here that's
worth looking at he says at most we can
say something like this for John Stuart
Mill's upbringing had given him a
limited view of human life and powers
had unfitted him for example for
appreciating games just because of the
way it had fitted him for appreciating
philosophy and then he goes on a little
bit further and he says
nonetheless the notion that the pursuit
of excellence in a way that extends
human powers is at the heart of human
life is instantly recognizable as at
home in not only John Stuart Mill's
political and social thought so not just
utilitarianism but also on Liberty and
remarks on representative government and
a number of other works as well but he
says but also in Hijaz and mrs. Taylor's
life and then McIntyre goes on and says
something really interesting worried to
choose human exemplars of certain of the
virtues as I understand them there would
be many names to name those who st.
Benedict st. Francis of Assissi st.
Teresa and those of Friedrich Engels and
Eleanor Marx and Leon Trotsky among them
notice he doesn't say Karl Marx but that
of John Stuart Mill would have to be
there certainly as any other and what
he's saying is that an Aristotelian
account or a McIntyre Ian account can
explain why these people's lives were
indeed virtuous in ways that those
people because of their intellectual
commitments wouldn't be able to
understand the virtues now the third
thing that he says is that his account
links evaluation and explanation in an
Aristotelian way now what does that
actually mean
he tells us that from a an Aristotelian
standpoint to identify certain actions
as manifesting or failing to manifest a
virtue of virtues is never only to
evaluate so you're not just saying good
or bad virtuous or vicious or something
in between instead you're also engaging
in what he calls explanation
he says it's also to take the first step
towards explaining why those actions
rather than some others were performed
so for an Aristotelian the fate of a
city or an individual can be explained
by citing the injustice of a tyrant or
the courage of its defenders and he says
without allusion to the place that just
as an injustice courage and cowardice
play in human life very little will be
genuinely explicable so this is a third
way in which he views his account as
aligned with with the fundamental
point of Aristotle that we can sort of
tease out from his works mostly again
the ethical political works and I will
close here by saying one thing about
interpreting Aristotle Aristotle very
often does things in outline and we
often have to piece together an account
from looking across the Aristotelian
corpus not just focusing on the nikah
michaiah ethics or just the politics but
reading the both of them together and
reading them in such a way that they
complement each other and bringing the
rhetoric in and bringing the topics in
and we could go on and on
with this and that is the sort of lens
through which MacIntyre is looking at
this and comparing his account to that
of Aristotle himself so he can say that
this is essentially an Aristotelian
account and it's a wrist Italian we
might say in enclosing this in a way
that's really in conformity with the
spirit of Aristotle's own approach which
is dialectical you take what works you
take what you think is actually still
viable and you pair off or strip away
the other parts and then you develop the
parts that you're going to keep even
furthers and that's what McIntyre is
doing in after virtue
you